we're gonna break the fourth wall
here and we're gonna title this video
how to get four movies on netflix in two
years
now we just need you to give us the nuts
and bolts
of how that happens and then we can put
that title on it okay
so now uh um are you saying from start
to finish
yeah what what so what are the four
movies and what are their genres maybe
we'll start with that
okay sure sure so uh yeah i i
was lucky enough to uh get to direct and
work on
uh four films that have all been
released in
this year 2020 on netflix um
which is kind of mind-boggling i was
never planned that way i think uh
um this year has brought a lot of
curveballs and um
a lot of people were looking for a lot
of content so it kind of worked out
but the first movie i did that was
released on netflix was roped
and it's a kind of coming of age a
little bit of
like a teen romance some have described
it as like a footloose meets
uh you know a western or something or a
rodeo movie
um and that was wonderful to work on
um and the two leads of that are josh
and lauren swickard
at the time lauren york but they
actually met and fell in love
on the set it was a real life romance
going on at the same time
that we were filming that movie the
second movie i did was lady driver
that was led by grace van dien and she's
i think a wonderful wonderful actress i
think she's a
big big star in the making and of course
sean patrick flannery
was in that with her as well and also
her dad did a cameo casper vandine
um and uh that's about a young
woman who becomes a race car champion or
pursues becoming a race car champion
um kind of in her it's kind of in her
family blood
and so again it's a coming of age it's
her kind of
figuring all that stuff out finding out
about her past that she didn't know
about
and then after that was this really zany
comedy it's my first feature comedy um
i've love
absolutely adore comedy and even in
action films i i try and put in comedy i
just love
the opportunity and the vehicle to try
and make people smile in any which way
that i can so i had done comedic
commercials
in the past and i've done short films
that are that are
comedy but never a feature so this was
my first feature
comedy and i had an absolute blast
making it's probably the most fun i've
ever had
on a set the actors and matt jones and
noreen dewolfe and maddie carderoppal
and
uh um
they're just we're so funny that you
know
in front of the camera off the camera
they're so funny that just the whole
experience was
just absolutely hilarious and john ducey
who wrote it was also in it
he's hilarious and his wife
christina moore is also in it so they're
just all such a funny
cast along with ali afshar
um that uh that one's that one's kind of
a
i don't know if many people will know
this movie but there's a movie called
brewster's millions and it's the
basically the the
nuts and bolts of it is uh strange
father
um leaves his fortune and his will to uh
to his his son and uh
um in our movie the son uh
he has two other siblings who believe
they should be the heirs to the
to the family fortune but
on his deathbed the father leaves a
challenge for his
his estranged son to be able to uh get
the family fortune
if he competes in these races across the
country and he has to podium
it's totally not believable it's totally
over the top but
basically he has to go across the
country and compete in different races
from motorcycle
like motocross to drag
drag boats to monster trucks i mean like
we did
we went across the gamut of the the
racing world and just had a blast with
it
and then the last one is which just came
out is california christmas
and that's just a very sweet kind of
rom-com
christmas movie and that again stars
josh and lauren swickard and at this
time she wrote the script
lauren swickard wrote it and produced it
and
along with ali afshar but it was a great
reunion
with them both acting in it now married
and um
we became very again what we talked
about earlier about
you know the relationships you build it
really that's exactly what this was all
about we had a great experience
on one project and we're trying to
figure out what to do you know in the
future when the time was right what can
we do again together and this is the
vehicle that came up for that
and i jumped at the chance as soon as i
got called
and said hey do you want to direct
another movie with josh and lauren
i'm like yes what is the well first
obviously i got to read the script but
almost like not even knowing the script
it was already like a yes like
you know yes i want to do another film
with them because it was just such an
enjoyable experience and
and uh this one it's the big city guy
comes and he's trying to buy the
property from the
from the the ranch from the young woman
who who
owns the ranch and so it's that kind of
thing and he gets
dragged into doing work on the on the
ranch and
of course they fall in love and uh you
know it's that kind of thing but there's
some good little twists in it and
there's some really fun characters that
are unexpected
uh in there and uh you know you've got
david del rio who's a really great
comedic actor
just a great actor in general but he's
also really really good at comedy
um and uh
he's really funny in this movie so um we
had a lot of fun with that
and uh yeah they all all of them
ended up on netflix uh this past year
and
or this year and that was uh uh i felt
just very
blessed that that is a reality you know
that that happened wasn't expecting it
um
you know you're making these movies you
don't necessarily know when they're
going to come out
um but yeah they
they all did and so how does that happen
is that something where you
knew up front that you were making these
to eventually be on netflix a
distributor got them on
the producer had inroads yeah so the
first three no
um the first three we didn't know
exactly what the distribution path would
be
uh california christmas is a netflix
original so yes we did know from the
get-go on that one
and there's that collaboration so
that was really exciting when we were
doing it too just knowing that we
that that that's going to be the home
this is you know
uh um just really and obviously then
there's the pressures of making sure you
do it right and do it justice and make
them happy and everything
but um the first three no we we
we made them with you know obviously
netflix would be a
a great place for them to land so you
shoot for those
shoot for that as a goal of course um
but uh
you know obviously there's uh amazon and
there's hulu and there's
there's theatrical there's you know just
going a traditional route like you know
itunes or whatever so there's all sorts
of different uh
avenues you could go um
but i definitely think netflix was a
goal place to try and get them
uh and luckily with the relationships uh
that uh
the production team and um like our
producers
like ali afshar the relationships he's
built
helped us get us into those doors and
ultimately get you know find their home
there
has has he had other movies on netflix
did he already have a pre-existing
relationship
so um
i think with roped the cut several of
them got released the same day so i
think it was a
a um kind of a little bit of a package
deal there
so i'm not exactly sure if there was
anything before that that had made it
onto netflix
i think those were the first ones so
no not necessarily but um relationships
with
with like we kind of have a kind of
loose partnership like sales partnership
with warner brothers
so that relationship was already
established
um and so i think it was through that
relationship again
some of this stuff is above my pay grade
but i do know that we
we have partnered especially on the
sales ends of things with warner
brothers in the past
and so that has been kind of a very good
relationship there with with several
movies
and then when it came to this um again
i am not 100 sure but i think that was
the the
the relationship that then uh bridged
into netflix
so so ali has these relationships and is
this from
i know he has a racing does something
with racism so yeah so
yeah ali ali um is uh
again he now i've done more movies with
him than i've done with anybody else
so our partnership him producing me
directing
i've done five films with him
and obviously i keep coming back because
i love working with him
and again it's another really
just great friendship that has developed
over the years and so um
uh he started he's got a great story so
he uh grew up in northern california
i also grew up in northern california so
there's a little bit of that you know
bond there
but he uh got into racing
uh kind of in a roundabout way but i
mean he was always into racing but
how he got sponsorships and everything
was him and his
team his buddies they figured out uh
how to um take a subaru
and modify it in a way to be
obviously incredibly fast but compete in
drag racing
and at that time subaru they're rally
racing and they did other things other
kinds of racing but
came nowhere near drag racing but
the way how he was able to figure out
how to take i believe it's a six
cylinder
and like drag race with these huge
muscle cars and win
was kind of uh revolutionary and
especially for
uh for subaru themselves and so
um if i'm remembering the story
correctly they came out to meet him and
he took them in the car and showed him
what it could do
and they wanted to sponsor him so he
traveled the world did all these races
and and got even
you know more advanced with the subarus
and took them to like
world record holding numbers and he uh
i believe he still holds some world
records with to his team and subaru
um with the drag racing so he did really
well for himself there and through
different sponsorship deals that's how
he met other sponsors who then
became hey why don't we make some movies
together would you want to make a movie
about race cars you know what i mean
so it became that that's how he kind of
got into that whole world
and i think he had also just done some
acting on the side because that was
another
passion of his um i know he was on like
king of queens he kind of had a
character who would come back every so
often
and i know he did some some of the stuff
early on as well
i don't know where that overlaps with
him making movies and all of that but um
he kind of tried to marry his two loves
i think which was racing and acting and
and uh and all of that so um they ended
up making a couple race car movies first
okay um and then that started bridge
bridging out from there
started expanding into other stories to
tell not just racing but
we do always kind of come back to the
racing too because that is
obviously a big passion of his so even
like our comedy
wheels of fortune um that i was
describing earlier
it's obviously all the different race
car elements i mean from the motorcycles
to the boats to the
off-road trucks to the you know it's uh
um we do find ways to do
do stories that uh also involve the
racing
right so interesting so he has this sort
of
mindset of of finding sponsors and and
partnering what he loves to do
with these bigger companies he's really
good at that again he's really good at
those relationship building and and that
we talked about earlier
he's uh he's very personable very nice
guy
all of those things and and and has
great ideas and has
you know this incredible ambition and
and uh
i think his energy is infectious that
way as well so i think
um he attracts uh those kinds of
uh people that with like-minded uh you
know energy and want
want to create these things and so um
i think he's produced it's really hard
to keep track of them all i think he's
produced 16 movies
and two television series now and all
within a matter of
you know five years or something like
that
or maybe even under that so um
yeah when he sets his mind to those
things he's he it really excels
and then luckily i was able to to
partner uh with him
and that was through um again we talk
about how
uh work begets work right so um
it was an actor named shane graham who's
also a wonderful actor i think he's a
big star as well
and he's he's doing really great work
he's got a movie right now called
ride which is on amazon and
that one's doing really really well and
again that's the same same filmmaker ali
afshar is also the producer of that
so he had just finished filming that
when he came onto a tv series
i was directing and uh we became fast
friends
and he uh said man i got to introduce
you to these other filmmakers
and he in kind told them you've got to
meet this director
sean you know i think you guys would get
along great so it's really him helping
bridge that
relationship and then um some of the
producers not ali came to set
and actually the other director the
other
main director for for ali's company esx
entertainment
uh alex uh rena revello has directed
i think he's directed like at least ten
movies with them i've done five
he's yeah yeah and uh um
so he um he came to set he came to visit
it's almost like the the you know if if
he approved of me then they would take a
meeting with me type of thing
and he was lovely and and uh he came to
set and visited when we were
we were launching some b-25 bomber it
was a world war ii thing
and uh i'll be like perfect day for him
to come see
we're doing some really cool stuff you
know so he came and visited and
and uh luckily
he reported back that that i seemed like
uh you know maybe a good match for them
as well so
i went out to warner brothers and and
met up with ali and
and again i think we we hit it off right
away and i really liked the story
the the movie that they were um
talking to me about directing at the
time is called american fighter
and that comes out in early early 2021
it's finally coming out so that one's
been
it's been a while since we first started
that one but it's finally coming out
i believe in march is when that one's
going to come out but um so i met with
them
and luckily they they
liked me enough and and the rest is
history i then did
four more movies after that one with
them and hopefully more
knock on wood uh i would love to do of
course
more projects with them wow that's
really fascinating so because i think
ali when i read his bio i said he he was
going to med school and then he became
he wanted to be an actor instead and
then the race car driving came in there
and then
is that that's fascinating then yeah
then yeah find the sponsorship
and that would take him back to acting
exactly
yeah yeah yeah it's really
it's really uh amazing and he's a great
producer that way i mean he
he's just one of those people that any
problem even you know i
i view myself as a great problem solver
but
i even run into certain issues that you
know maybe i can't tackle he comes in
and it's
and he fixes it you know i we were
shooting lady driver
and it had just rained and we're on this
it's this really nasty kind of clay
that just will your cars will sink in
and all that kind of stuff and and you
won't get them out like
it's one of those things so it had
rained a couple days before we were at
this
race track and we're supposed to film
everything in there
in their race pits um and
but the problem is it had rained a
couple days and the the the track
the guy running the track was like i
don't think you can bring these big
heavy
you know production trucks and vehicles
on here
and he goes we'd have to bring in a
tractor and we'd have to like you know
lay down so like like till it up and lay
down some more stuff and blah blah
i'm like well where are we gonna film
this you know like this is here
today is here's our schedule this is
what we're supposed to film on this day
and i kept talking to the guy going what
can we do where can we film it can we do
it here or
is there any way to to make it work
there can we bring the tractor he goes
no i don't think it can happen
then my producer my field producer comes
in he's talking to him nope can't happen
nope can't
everybody nope can't happen here comes
ali
what's wrong what's going on i go well
because it rained here we can't get the
vehicles out there as well he goes
he goes okay hold on up he goes two
minutes he's over there talking to the
gentleman comes back is yeah we're going
to be able to film there
what how did you make that happen he's
just one of those people that just
you know makes those kinds of things
happen of course the guy got the tractor
he did all the work you know i don't
know i don't know what they said or what
was talked about but
you know he was able to to make that
happen and we filmed the whole day where
we were supposed to film it and and it
all worked out
and uh and yeah so very interesting
sean can you further explain how you got
the first two films
on netflix yeah so i think the the first
couple films that we got on there
had to do with the relationship with
warner brothers and them kind of being
the
handling the sales of the films if that
makes sense
so um they're the ones who
and i say they i really again a lot of
this is above my pay grade but
um i know it was a relationship with
warner brothers representing the films
to sell them
and they sold it to netflix so that's
how they got it on there and i believe
it was a package deal
again it's above my pay grade but um
uh i believe that's how the first couple
of films got on there
and of course then the relationship
builds and then we got a couple more on
there and that went really well for us
and then
you know now we've got the newest one
california christmas that just came out
so i think we have
um it's not just my four films uh with
the same company with esx and ali's
ally's company i think we now have seven
films on there
on netflix so it's been a the
relationship obviously
through warner brothers has built and
it's been really really fantastic
and sorry how did you get the first
relationship going with warner brothers
and i know
that part's not i have no you have no
clue yeah that's that's uh that's all
ally
right that's his relationship so i don't
know how that all
started right you've been a director for
hire on all four movies
that have gone to netflix were you
competing with other directors at that
time for the job
um i do know um
yes i think there's always been other
directors in consideration
uh a few of them know i think we just
from the get-go we knew that i was going
to do it and that's because we had
already established that relationship
um but yes there was other
i guess because american fighter was the
first film i directed with them and
there was other directors being
considered
uh but that one hasn't come out yet that
one's not on netflix yet that one is
released in
again in march um
so that one i knew i definitely was
competing uh
and there's always there is also the
alex arena rubella who has directed a
bunch of movies with them so
it's like are you gonna direct this one
you gonna direct you know we also have
brett hedland who has been the editor on
all of our films he also directed a film
for esx
um called the stand at paxton county uh
which i helped develop that script
um but he ended up uh directing it
because i was directing uh wheels of
fortune
so i think yeah there's those things and
and uh certain ones uh
yes there's other uh in consideration
and other ones it's been
you know hey we love what you do we want
you
you know we think you could tell the
story really well and so i just get
offered it
but certainly in the beginning there was
definitely more of that
considering other directors for the
projects
did you personally meet with anybody at
netflix did you go to netflix
no you haven't okay no yeah i haven't
had any i have met with people from
netflix before but not for these movies
um uh again uh
being the director i'm not the producers
of them i'm not i don't have
i am very uh involved in the
post-production process
from everything editing visual effects
sound design
adr score i i
i have my fingers in every single part
of that uh
but and making sure that the
deliverables
get done but beyond that
like i said it's kind of but my pay
grade and um
i'm not involved on that level now if it
would be something that i produced
then that might be more the case and i
have had those conversations with
films that are i have personally
produced you know that are
through my stuff but but um uh
i did have a movie long ago on netflix
but it was when there were still
dvds that they would send to your house
um
so i remember those days yeah it's
exciting to check the mail
um how much involvement does netflix
have during production i know you said
with california christmas
yeah this is our first this is our first
um uh
uh netflix original so yeah there is a
certain involvement and again warner
brothers
uh they're also those relationships
there
um kind of overseeing making sure
everything's going good and and all that
i think because of when we filmed this
we were one of the first
films after this pandemic has started to
come back and film
there was tv shows some docu-series that
had been going
but we were one of the first film film
productions to go back in
so i think there's uh because of those
reasons
it's maybe a different experience than
it would have been
uh prior to this um so there's not a
whole bunch of people that just randomly
come into sets like everything is very
small
controlled um there was some you know
zoom sessions in those kinds of things
from
from more of the executives uh you know
in that regard but esx was in charge of
producing
the product but yes from script levels
to overseeing
sending clips sending data you know
whatever it is
their involvement is that way but not um
coming to set and and uh overseeing it
in that respect
at least not on this again like i said i
think because of um
uh just the current uh world affairs
that that uh
um it was more from afar you know what i
mean
sure but so you were sending them
dailies i know those dailies or like
certain scenes cut together scenes here
that show you a sample you know
those kinds of things but the way that
we do dailies now it's all digital it's
all up on there so
again i'm not sure what sent to who
because i'm so
razor focused on filming and getting the
stuff done
but very likely it could have been sent
to them to review
yeah and they reviewed the script and
gave you notes
yes yeah yeah all that stuff was of
course they have to have
uh approval on all that kind of stuff
sean forgive me for asking this but
the timeline can we just go over that
one more time for these
movies because it sounds like it's
happened so fast yeah this year has been
very interesting
again i think i think because people are
so starving for content
it's why so many of my projects came out
but roped in lady driver kind of came
out at the same time on netflix
and so those were already out then
we were already in development and and
working on a california christmas
before wheels of fortune came out so
we're actually on set
filming a california christmas oh i'm
sorry actually was after a california
christmas stopped filming
when uh um i was on a different
television a different
project when uh wheels of fortune came
out
um and uh so yeah so it was
had a couple of them on there we i don't
remember if the
i think the deal was in place when we
started filming california christmas
four wheels of fortune to come out um
but it didn't come out until after we
were done filming it and then
you know the california christmas is the
one we had the clearest like
date of when where it was going to
release because it's holiday movie
we knew december they wanted it to come
out in early december
to play through for the holidays so um
but on like wheels of fortune we didn't
know what the date exactly would be when
when netflix would want to drop it when
they want to release it obviously
i'm sure they have specific you know
reasons for when they want to
to release uh movies um but i do believe
we have the deal for
for wheels of fortune while you know
before we started filming
uh california christmas if i'm not
mistaken again
a lot of this stuff is i i don't get to
deal with it i don't get the inside
information on that but
um but yeah uh so i had two films
already
but also esx i believe already had four
films
on uh on netflix already released
before we started doing the california
christmas
project and that just came out today
you